in a summer of shark sightings racist
tweets from the White House and children
held in cages along the southern border
we may have lost sight of the distinct
possibility we could end up at war with
Iran some suggests were already engaged
in a tit-for-tat
cyber war Iran has seized a British ship
claims it disrupted a CIA spy network
and after in what the US says is a
deliberately provocative manner in the
strategic shipping lanes of the gulf of
Hormuz and while president Trump has not
authorized any military action he has
disclosed the US has conducted cyber
attacks on Iran and issued a stern
warning we'll see what happens with Iran
Iran has to be very very careful joining
us now to talk about all this is Karen
Greenberg the executive director of the
Center for national security at the
Fordham Law School and by Skype from
Cambridge Massachusetts Matt bond a
professor at Harvard one of the world's
great experts on nuclear proliferation
and terrorism thank you both for being
here Matt but let me start with you do
you think we're on the brink of
something I think it's very dangerous
right now
we have a situation in the fairly
crowded Strait of Hormuz with lots of
different military forces operating not
only there but in Iraq in Yemen in Syria
there are lots of things that could
clash inadvertently and be the spark for
the beginning of a war meanwhile there
is strong tensions because of the
sanctions that the United States has
imposed after pulling out of the Iran
nuclear deal so there's and there's no
negotiations underway to resolve the
situation so that the situation is
really fraught with danger at the moment
I think and you feel one false step
could lead to something quite disastrous
indeed we've seen situations before
where things happened that neither a
commander actually wanted to happen in
1988 a u.s. ship shot down a Iranian
civilian air
killing everyone aboard during the Cuban
Missile Crisis there were all sorts of
events that almost led to war that
neither Khrushchev nor Kennedy ordered
to happen so there's just like there's a
fog of war there's a fog of crisis that
can lead to events that nobody wanted to
have happen let me ask you there's been
talk of a cyber war already underway
with attacks from both sides at each
other yeah it's almost like a parallel
conversation that's going on in the
conflict between the United States and
Iran and what you're seeing is parallel
to the Caesar ships the shooting down of
drones that we've seen what you've seen
is a parallel war going on lots of it we
know we don't hear about what we've
heard about some of it which has to do
with us attacking Iranian intelligence
networks and Iranians targeting our
financial and other networks and some of
its theft some of it's ransomware and
some of it's just to show that they can
do it but it is more getting more and
more intense it's been going on over the
course of the last couple of months and
it has not helped by the fact that the
bellicose language from the president
makes it so that he's pushing Iran
further and further you know first he he
withdraws from the jcpoa then he
declares the IRGC
a terrorist organization it said and
then we begin to retaliate both in terms
of activity and in terms of rhetoric so
I agree with Matt we are in an extremely
dangerous situation without a real sense
of who would be in command to say this
is what should happen either in the
cyber space or in the kinetic space so
far no shots fired but president Trump
has acknowledged a cyber attack no
absolutely and and no shots have been
fired but leading national security
experts often say that the next war the
next hot war we see will be introduced
via cyber war and so how you make that
distinction what the moment becomes
where it becomes kinetic and and violent
and causes death is a matter of time met
but do you think that this cyber war
could lead to a shot
being fired absolutely and arguably
their shots being fired already in the
sense that there were these mines that
damaged several tank tankers that were
attributed to the Iranians
there was the shoot-down of the American
drone President Trump launched a
military strike on Iran which he called
off at the very last moment so I I think
we're closer than many Americans realize
to the brink there are senior people in
the administration who believe that it
would be a good thing to have military
strikes against Iran to take out parts
of their nuclear program I personally
think that would be a disastrous
potentially catastrophic move because we
could set their nuclear program back but
only for a few years and they would
likely rebuild in secret and there are
many things throughout the Middle East
that they could do in response there's a
real danger of setting the whole Middle
East even more on fire than it already
is and Karen in a war like that huge
casualties listen people have been
starting to talk about the difference
between the war with Iraq and what a war
with Iran would be and estimates of
people who live through the Iraq war in
positions of command and official
authority have said almost to a person
that the Iran war would dwarf what the
Iraq war looked like and and again the
allegations of they're tied to the
greatest terrorist organizations in the
world are just not true and the amount
of impact that Iran has been able to
have in Syria in Yemen and elsewhere has
been much less than the rhetoric
surrounding it and so I do think we are
in a dangerous situation and I think it
and there's also as Matt pointed out in
the beginning not a minor point the lack
of diplomacy that is that is has any
kind of space now I think you might have
seen that foreign minister Zarif has
offered to talk to the members of
Congress that's interesting because
there's a hunger for diplomacy it has to
happen and right now there are no
avenues for it Karen Greenberg from the
National Security Center at foreign law
thank you very much
bun and Harvard thank you very much for
joining us tonight